"Can we make climate action feel
happy instead of miserable?"
The current narrative on climate action is
drive less,eat less meat, shop less.
Less, less, less.
So we came up with what we
call the happy climate approach.
It's actions in the sweetspot
that not only reduce emissions
but also make you feel happier
at the same time.
Instead ofshopping often,
make shopping a treat.
Feng shui your fridge.
Catch things before they rot.
By moving the perishables to the door
and the condiments into the drawers.
Instead of saying "drive less,"
we should say “drive more ...
people."
Because carpooling can turn those
dreadful minutes behind the wheel
into joyful momentsof socializing.
Bundle your trips,
cutting out unnecessary flights can
contribute to a senseof time affluence.
The feeling that you have enough
time to do what you want to do.
Thinkabout the actions you
can take in your own life